in a city that is not easily shocked the
murder of investigative reporter Jeff
gurman was a shock
this is a terrible and jarring homicide
one that has deeply impacted Las Vegas
every murder is tragic
but the killing of a journalist is
particularly troublesome
Jeff was a hell of a reporter and
according to what we're seeing so far
that's what got him killed
that's what it appears to be I I'll tell
you I'm surprised we thought it was
probably a robbery gone bad uh until it
all came down to being this guy who he
wrote about the first lead for police
was a neighborhood surveillance camera
showing a person wearing an orange shirt
with reflective stripes and a straw hat
carrying a duffel bag
on that morning he approached Mr
garman's home and at that time
our victim was stabbed multiple times
there were two main areas that we were
focused on early on one was ensuring
that this was not connected to a
burglary series or anything of the sort
and then two looking at any work-related
grievances or conflicts related to Mr
gearman's work for years German had
taken on mobsters and corrupt
politicians in his stories for the Las
Vegas Sun and the Las Vegas Review
Journal his most recent series of
investigative stories focused on a local
politician caught on tape in the back
seat of a vehicle with a woman who was
not his wife
his name was Robert Tellis the county
public administrator apparently he
created a hostile work environment uh
was rude was unprofessional to his staff
and also carried on an affair with a
subordinate that the other employees
ended up getting video of the two of
them in the back seat
um which they gave to Jeff
and tell us tonight everything in an
interview with government when you hear
people raising these allegations about
you and Roberta
uh come on you know personal
relationship that you have what how do
you what do you say to people about that
honestly it's not true I said and
you know all of my friends all my family
know how much I love my wife
I am about nothing but Justice fairness
and just just being a good person
and it it sickens me it destroys me that
that somebody would even level like
accusations like that
because it's
I don't know it's
it's unreal it's unreal the lengths that
they're going to they don't have any
clones
trying to to ruin my personal life
to
to get to win this race
Telos was defeated in the next election
did Jeff ever indicate that this man
might be violent no no I mean I think
there were some indications that he was
uh hostile and uh unpleasant in the
Jeff's stories but Jeff never and the
guy you know attacked him on Twitter and
said he was a bad reporter and this is
the kind of stuff we all get uh as
investigative reporters but he never
thought that he was in danger clearly or
he I mean would have taken some
precautions he never told me that if
there was ever any concern about
personal safety it most likely would
have been because of gurman's reporting
on Las Vegas Mobsters you know the mob
was very prominent here uh up through
the you know the early 1980s and that's
when Jeff got his start here and he
wrote about the mob uh never you know as
far as we know he was never threatened
uh in this way by the mob so uh it's a
it's a little ironic that uh you know
many years later uh it's uh it's a
politician at a very low level in this
case who Maybe the corporate you know
investigative reporters make enemies
that's part of what they do for a living
but to my knowledge a politician killing
a reporter can you think of anything
else like that anywhere in this country
you know the the notion of a reporter
being killed for doing their job is is
very unusual uh in America right we we
hear about this and reporters tragically
being killed in Mexico in large numbers
but this almost never happens uh in
America so your point you know that the
actual politician who was targeted uh by
the reporter actually committing a crime
is is unprecedented as far as I I my
history uh tells me
the judge rules that the Clark County
official charged with murder in the
Fatal stabbing of review journal's
investigative reporter Jeff gearman will
be held without bail Clark County public
administrator Robert Tellis made his
initial court appearance this afternoon
and finally let me ask you what will be
a Jeff's Legacy
Jeff was kind of the ultimate Vegas
reporter he's been here 30 years
he covered the mob he covered the MGM
Grand fire he's covered pretty much
every important story so his legacy is
going to be hard-hitting real
journalists Die Hard reporter till the
end
foreign